Kelly Ripa has officially named her  permanent co-host for the ABC morning  talk show he or she is ready to come out  and start his or her new job would you  like to meet him or her  [Applause]  are you nervous don't be nervous you  look great okay here we go let's do this  Kelly Ripa  and ryan seacrest  that's right it's live with Kelly and  ryan seacrest Ripper revealed on Monday  that the former American Idol host will  shared the daytime TV desk as her new  co-host it is Monday May 1st 2017 guess  what else it's also my wedding day and  Noma TV is anniversary after the big  announcement Seacrest took to Twitter to  gush about his new gig quote so excited  to join this show Kelly Ripa crushes it  every morning one of my favorite people  ever  [Music]